Speaker 1: Listen to today's voicemail
kind of bums me out. It's about Cuba,
and we talk sometimes about the revolutionary
left, it's a sort of pseudo populism on the left,
which sometimes blinds people to authoritarianism
and the lack of progressivism and authoritarianism
where they end up supporting these, you know,
often military uniform wearing faux populists.
And I've been talking this week about how
the U.S. has some blame for the situation
in Cuba thanks to the hypocritical and
counterproductive U.S. embargo of Cuba.
I want the embargo to be dropped. I don't want
American involvement in Cuban politics. And yet
I cannot, as a progressive, support something as
authoritarian as the Castro regime, which came
to power in 1959, handed power from brother
to brother in 2008. That's not progressive.
That's just not progressive. And sadly, I did
get a voicemail. It's very long. I'll only play
some of it from a revolutionary leftist who
doesn't like my perspective. Take a listen.
Speaker 4: I'm really disappointed
in you the way you're framing Cuba
politically. You are purposefully leaving out the
full context. Fidel Castro is not start out as a
dictator nor a dictator wannabe.
Speaker 1: So, first of all,
didn't start out as a dictator, conceding
that that's eventually what he became.
Speaker 4: OK, he was a reaction to stuff. I
see the regime friendly to the United States
corporate industrial oligarchy. Sure. The people
in Cuba uprose because they were sick and tired of
being paid lousy wages. Sure, they didn't want to
be serfs for the American industrial machine. OK,
Fidel Castro, I believe he was educated in the
United States. And so he had a rule that one out
on his fellow Cubans and he made sure that they
understood the true nature of what was going on.
Speaker 1: Listen, this is how faux populist
authoritarians work. The fact that Castro came to
power in a context where there was genuine real in
the streets. Dissatisfaction with Cuban leadership
doesn't change the fact that this is how faux
populism works. It's the populist rhetoric.
And next thing you know, the same guys in
power for forty nine years with a police state,
with complete and total control over every
aspect of the people and end of the economy, the
fact that Castro replaced something bad and that
those who were protesting in the 50s in Cuba did
so genuinely and for good reasons, doesn't mean
that we praise Fidel Castro in power since 1959,
until 2008, at which point he hands power to his
brother. It's not progressive. I can't support it.
And this is you know, it's a very similar
playbook to Venezuela because in the 50s,
there were reasons to protest. Doesn't mean we now
don't criticize what is an authoritarian regime.
Even the military uniforms similar between,
you know, the Castro green uniform and Hugo
Chavez and Nicolas Maduro in Venezuela appearing
sometimes and, you know, essentially military
dress uniforms. And it's sort of disturbing to
me that supposed progressives not only fall for
the faux populist rhetoric, but they even fall for
like even the military uniform stuff doesn't raise
alarms to you. The suspicion that these folks have
of the military uniform when it's the U.S. or the
U.K. military seems to go out the window. When you
see the same sort of stuff being done in Cuba and
in Venezuela, I will never get it. And again, I
at this point, I've done this so many times when
I do these political compass type tests, I am not
an authoritarian leftist. I'm a small libertarian
leftist. So I can't as a progressive, support
authoritarian regimes. And it makes me sad when
when people who sometimes think of themselves as
progressive support, that is just disappointing.
We have a great bonus show for you today. Sign
up it. Join Patman Dotcom. We'll see you then.